alors vous allez ouvrir le coffre de
votre véhicule vous mettez la pièce
d'identité à plat dans le coffre
services sans contact parfois même
directement dans le coffre pour cette
cliente le mois de confinement a rendu
nécessaire cet achat l'enseigne met en
avant des produits de nécessité
j'avais un besoin d'imprimantes parce
que mes enfants sont à la maison comme
beaucoup pour mon travail aussi je vais
avoir besoin d'imprimer très bonne idée
ça va parce que je suis tombé en panne
de table a dit hier soir et je m'attable
est aujourd'hui c'est parfait parce
qu'il faut maintenir la vie familiale et
notamment les les anniversaires
donc il y avait la possibilité à deux
ferait un cadeau donc j'en ai profité
j'habite pas très loin depuis le 14
avril
l'enseigne spécialisés installés à
coignières propose un driver piétons
habituellement ouverts 7 jours sur 7
avec 50 collaborateurs
le magasin fonctionne pour le moment
avec six salariés volontaires
la règle est claire la sécurité avant
tout aussi bien pour les clients mais
surtout pour les collaborateurs
donc les clients n'ont pas le droit et
ne rentreront pas en magasin des tables
ont été mises en avant par rapport à ça
l'idée c'est vraiment con qu'on se
protège et encore une fois que le client
aussi soient protégés ce qui est ce qui
est demandé un principalement c'est
vraiment le petit électroménager avec ce
qui se passe on a beaucoup de clients
qui cherchent eux mêmes je pense à faire
leurs pattes leur pain et leur cuisine
donc on commande on a pas mal de robots
justement qui arrivent dans les yvelines
trois autres magasins de la franchise
ont mis en place ce type de drive de
nombreuses enseignes ont adopté ce
système de vente notamment dans le
bricolage et la restauration